well tis the season season where we all
think about what we're going to do this
year differently because we all know the
definition of insanity is continuing to
do the same thing over and over again
and expecting a different result you do
get to control a large portion of your
destiny Mike Todd said I've never been
poor I've only been broke poor is a
state of mind when we were broke we
didn't want to look at where we were so
we looked at where we're going you know
you can walk through sewage if you look
past it if you look down at it then you
get to be part of it right if you ever
let you know I don't look down don't
look down because you'll stay there you
know look past it you go where you look
did you know that watch the attitude and
the altitude of your chin and your head
and your eyes because you're gonna go
where you look if you've ever played
sports so many sports you go where you
look I was a competition water skier
back in college we used to do these
shows and stuff and I still barefoot by
the way I'm 57 shut up so there you go
but I got this bright idea these guys
that were ski jumpers going over the
water ski going over the jumps you've
seen them I don't know if you ever
watched one of those guys or not the
really good ones I mean like the ones
that compete and that kind of stuff as
they go over their body it's kind of
like a snow ski jump as well your body
leans forward into it to the point that
your tip your chin almost touches the
tips of your skis but you know where
their eyes are their eyes are looking in
the distance at the top of some Hill
they are not looking down now I didn't
do anything like that I just went over
the jump like you know and I wrote it
out so shut up the second time the first
time I fell but I wrote it out and it's
a little slicker and weirder than you
think it is gonna be I'll just tell you
there's a long time ago but I still
remember
I'll tell you the thing they kept
telling us over and over and over was
pick out and pick out a place out there
in the distance on the horizon and look
at the top of one of those hills because
you're going to go where you look and if
you look down you will barrel roll off
of that jump and those skis and
everything else will hit you as you fall
in the water and talk to you about
having looked down when you look down
that's where you're gonna go barefooting
is the same way if you look down you
look at your feet you want to be all
happy about riding on your feet in the
water you're gonna be in the water
you're gonna fall and like people
hitting you with a bat it hurts so bad
so you go where you look but life is a
lot the same way it a lot of a lot of
sports are that way you that the tilt of
your head the looking of your eyes where
are you gonna go where there is no
vision the people perish so this is the
time of year you set goals goals that
work have to be five things you've heard
me cover this before if you've listened
to this show I didn't invent these
things I read them and stole them from
the Masters in the business like the zig
Zigler zuv the world goals that work
have to be specific and they have to be
measurable goals that work have to have
a time frame they have to be your goals
and they have to be in writing let me
walk through that again if goals aren't
specific and measurable the first two
things they're not a goal they're a wish
I want to lose weight this year you
won't it's measurable but you weren't
specific I want to raise my income this
year you won't it's measurable but as it
wasn't specific very specific I want to
make a hundred thousand dollars this
year oh okay it's a goal that's specific
it's measurable
I want to lose 30 pounds good it's
specific it's measurable now you got the
first two elements of a goal a properly
set goal worked out then it has to have
a time limit I want to lose 30 pounds
win over 40 years and how many times do
you want lose 30 pounds Yeah right
all those 30 pounds win in 90 days oh
now we got a goal see you know what just
happened all of you started doing math
as soon as we put 90 days on it 3 months
30 pounds what is that how much a month
10 pounds a month how much a week two
and a half
pounds a week what do you got to do
increase my heart rate decrease the
intake especially sugars and bread drop
the caloric intake increase the heart
rate and the clerk burn sweat 30 minutes
a day at least and that's not in the
sauna you actually have to workout and
when you know the things you have to do
you don't have that's copra you know
what to do this is how you lose weight
you have a specific thing you have a
time limit and immediately you start
asking yourself what has to be true to
hit that goal in that time limit I want
to pay off sixty thousand dollars worth
of debt when this year
oh that's five thousand dollars a month
it's twelve hundred fifty bucks a month
a week what's your income what do you
got to do what do you got to sell what
have you got a what kind of extra income
have you got to take on to make that
goal happen what have you got cut out of
your budget oh you got to do a budget as
soon as you put it in writing and it's
specific and it's measurable you start
to have a goal the in writing is number
four it's got to be in writing it's got
to be in writing it's got to be in
writing it's not in writing it's not a
goal write it down type it out on your
computer 78 point and put it on your
mirror that's simple put it on this
phone screen so every time you open your
phone it's looking at you just make
yourself where it's in your face
something happens when you put it in
writing that causes you to commit to it
it's almost like you made a contract
with your spirit the Bible says in
Habakkuk 2 to write the vision make it
plain you can speak a vision and that's
one thing but when you write it down you
can not only share it with others and
when you do that you put peer pressure
on yourself in a positive way in writing
and the goals have to be your goals I
can't be my wife wants me to lose weight
you know won't work my mother wants me
to make more money won't work my mother
always wanted me to be a dentist I don't
wanna be your patient
my father always wanted me to be a
preacher I don't wanna be in your
congregation unless you're speaking
about your heavenly father goals that
aren't your goals you're living someone
else's life which is a pretty shallow
existence don't do that set a goal that
you own emotionally you go I want to do
this why are you going through this
battle saying my husband thinks I need
to do that
rather a stupid there's no spiritual
growth in that at all
just compliance no no on purpose on
paper
specific measurable you only set goals
that are financial goals this year set
goals that are intellectual goals the
average millionaire reads a nonfiction
book a month they can't tell you who got
thrown off the island set goals their
family goals like specifically when
you're with your family turn off your
screens all of them the televisions the
phones something like that spiritual
goals maybe you're going to start
attending church this year for the first
time ever maybe I mean really attend
like be there on a Sunday maybe you're
gonna set some physical goals
weight-loss you're gonna run your first
marathon or half-marathon may be career
goals maybe it's time to change that job
you hate social goals maybe you make a
list of people you're actually going to
have dinner with instead of lying doing
them and saying let's get together
sometime write it down
make it happen it's your life it's not
going to happen on accident requires
intentionality this is the Dave Ramsey
show